le 31 juillet 2017 des centaines de
passagers restent coincés de longues
heures sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
d'Ottawa c'est une fin de vacances
brutale pour Kim Leclerc des aulniers on
est resté à peu près 6 heures sur le
Tarma après notre vol de 8h et la suite
ne sera pas plus facile pour la
voyageuse
ils m'ont dit oh mais c'est à cause de
tawa
me disait non c'est la faute
elle se tourne alors vers le fils des
transports du Canada qui forcera Air
Transat à dédommager les passagers
Ottawa décide alors de mettre en place
une charte des voyageurs mais
visiblement cela n'a pas permis de
soulager les maux de tête des passagers
et la pandémie a accentué les problèmes
dans la dernière année l'Office a reçu
45000 plaines contre des compagnies
aériennes on doit protéger encore
davantage leurs doigts le ministre des
Transports ajuste le
tirera d'emblée les compagnies aériennes
à indemniser les voyageurs sans qu'il
n'ait à en faire la preuve sauve de
rares circonstances il y aura aussi des
exigences pour les bagages retardés ici
ce n'est pas respecté les compagnies
devront répondre contiennent des
voyageurs en moins de 30 jours et les
amendes seront 10 fois plus élevées
pouvant atteindre 250 000 dollars si
l'aéroport est prêt mais la compagnie
aérienne est primé les douaniers il y en
a pas assez de bonnes nouvelles selon
les directeur de l'observatoire de
l'aviation civile mais il rappelle que
les compagnies aériennes ne sont pas les
seuls responsables de la fluidité dans
les aéroports
alors que c'est la responsabilité de
l'aéroport ou c'est la responsabilité
des douaniers ça ce n'est pas correct je
pense qu'il va falloir
clarifier cette chose là et le
gouvernement ne veut pas aller sur ce
terrain là parce que ça nécessite des
investissements la priorité du ministre
pour l'instant de faire adopter avant le
37 ans de la nouvelle mouture de la
Charte des voyageurs pour ce qui est de
faire sa part pour raccourcir les délais
de nouveaux investissements ne sont pas
sur son radar la somme de 1,8 milliards
de dollars annoncé dans le dernier
budget devra suffire ici Valérie Gamache
Radio-Canada
Ottawa